hello welcome to this video playing a
lexer Wow cut minus 6 go against how is
that possible yeah sometimes we are not
really comfortable in some way okay and
the check read only and i don't know if
i have to get do something about be five
I looked away for I think I do hmm
interesting okay I'll just go be 3r okay
three making normal moves oh wait 0n
like g6 97 on probably am preparing
later f5 yeah are not every eight and
then f5a i will i will answer with f4
anyway so let's see him and Drago look
be one or look III
yeah I guess we'll be one so f for if it
takes it I cannot take where the night
which is a bit of a shame but not much
that I can do about it would have liked
to take with a knighthood this also
should be okay so I need to move the
Queen question is where maybe here
covering e4
hmm
hmm that doesn't look so great again I
don't know why what did i do wrong I
don't know okay let's take it play 94
next I'm just playing this damn quickly
ok I think I probably have to have to go
I need you fire I really need you for
pushing pushing away if I can get this
in without some some some ok so GG for
what's the deal ok if you just like
cakes and goes back then I man in grey
in good shape doesn't seem to be a
tactic ok I cannot take on g6 I think
it's not yet possible if i go to g2 here
I rather want to go to g two nite you
force a little bit irritating but it
doesn't seem to work
a continues to play super quickly
threatening to take on g7 now and then
96
what and don't get it sorry check why is
this will check he just gives the he
just gives you peace okay it is not
working objectively okay now 96 should
be almost impossible to defend against
how to win this now chief g5 I guess
it's got 95 then
time warning hmm I want to try want to
try to win this directly not not with
technical play because of my time but I
don't see how
I've got 30 seconds oh how I hate this
all right so it's a totally one-sided
game and then you still have to struggle
because of the damn time unbelievable
stuff
check this is probably how I have that
bad score answer sky it's the doors and
at the end I screw up because of the
time
it actually would be an interesting
position to play but I will lose on time
no matter what check check
no I'm done during a bishop I just take
it yeah what a great game check check
still winning you may be no no no
probably not as he can take you five but
I've got one second here white foreheads
oh I'm such an idiot suction indeed what
it but it totally what again yeah when
is his old lady anyway but then he just
just blunt us this night yeah for for
nothing check check still managed to
screw up this is total win unbelievable
ah and everything winds here probably
why what do I take 30 seconds this is
just so utterly idiotic 93 second 39
seconds I take for that move I mean well
what absolutely every move wins I mean
everyone yeah I just have to catch up on
the clock here a little bit and bye bye
now it's getting tricky and I know I
know by now with 30 seconds that I would
lose on time because he's got two
minutes something and then I also start
to play where moves of course that this
is probably not winning any more the
engine still gives it as winning but I
have my doubts we should before we
should be three maybe it's so wins yeah
this was a it was a complicated position
um yeah I don't know this should be five
King Ashwin he has to improve somehow
but he just played like 27 and accepted
to be clearly worse after g4 maybe he
has to to do so he has to do something
else engine gives 90 of 6cm
like this check that gives us about
equal now with all those traits it's
it's believable yeah yeah black just
accepts to be clear diverse because of
all the weaknesses and the bad pieces T
any blunders the piece and I still don't
yeah it's kind of crazy yeah I don't
know sometimes I think I really get
irritated I have a very bad score
against people then let take even longer
for four simple moves Chang this is just
utterly idiotic then to take to take 39
seconds for that well really everything
wins literally you just have to be quick
enough to get the game finished yes
sorry for the renting but those kind of
games frustrate me they really do okay
thanks for watching